Well now we're getting somewhere.
All we have to do is run
those table creation queries
by calling exact SQL
at the end of our onCreate function.
But wait, there's another function
in our SQliteOpenHelper, onUpgrade.
You might think,
why should I care about those?
I'm not upgrading anything yet.
To make our development lives easier,
we're going to implement
the most standard kind
of onUpgrade there is.
You see onUpgrade only fires
if you change the version
of your database.
Now remember, we passed that version
into the SQliteOpenHelper
base constructor, ages ago.
Since we are going to be using
our database as a cache for web data
and not for user generated content,
we'll drop the tables.
This is helpful if we want to change
the database in the future.
If we were using user data,
we'd do something like use alter table
to add new columns.
So, now we have a database.